the very bottom it says this dome no
this domain is not for sale
please do not inquire about purchasing
it all emails from anonymous are unknown
companies asking me a price will be
ignored
sorry last updated july 2007
right so i emailed this guy i was like
hey uh saw your
website um like i think it's awesome
that you're not trying to sell this but
i'm curious like why aren't you trying
to sell this
and he's like refuses to monetize it
refuses to sell it i think it's
hilarious
what what is this
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
better let's talk about business ideas
um first of all let me give you an
update did you see someone in the
facebook group
um launched a pickleball newsletter
because we told them to
uh a few months ago because we told you
and it's now it's now their full-time
job
and they traveled the country uh getting
their products into stores and things
like that so it started as a pickleball
newsletter
right and then they partnered with the
pro tour of pickleball which
i don't know it was a thing and then
they started selling their own stuff
out of a van their own pickleball
equipment and now they're in retail
stores
what's your name give a shout out thomas
shields good job thomas
thomas um looks like a young kid he
looks like uh
a younger better looking version of me
uh
let's see what i can't uh yeah he looks
young he looks real
young so congratulations thomas shield
that's great i think the
ceo or the founder of pickleball either
listens to the pod or he messaged once
being like yeah i'm down to come on so
we we can have them on if you ever want
to
we could do an episode about how like
alternative sports basically and do some
research and have them on as well
great and speaking of alternative sports
you want to talk about chess
yeah so i have a follow-up there i don't
know if you have one or or just what i
put there
um go ahead what were you gonna say so
we talked about the background is we
talked about chess.com last episode i
tweeted about it because i was even more
people loved that tweet dude that tweet
had tons of engagement
um it was good and the the summary of
this
is that i actually we underestimated it
so chess.com gets around 200 million
monthly uniques
they have 60 million registered users
they
uh traffic has grown significantly if i
had a guest they do at least 100 million
in recurring revenue subscription
revenue
uh potentially is worth a billion
dollars super fascinating company
um go ahead what were you gonna say we
were trying to hype it and we actually
were under hyping even even though we
were trying to hype it um
and by the way the guy who started he's
like a ex stanford guy or the guy who
owns it
has two i think stanford guys uh which
is cool like
you know they didn't go the same track
probably as 95 percent of their
classmates and they're going to
outperform
99 of them just by by doing something
really simple that the world wanted
so i started thinking about this because
we talked about it you brought it up
cool topic cool bit really cool business
it really fits the what we call the new
zealand type of business that andrew
wilkinson kind of
coined that that phrase which is it's
this independent thing
it has like a cult following it's
profitable it's simple
it's nobody competes with it it's like
new zealand nobody's going to war with
with chess.com
uh you know the biggest competitor i
think it's called lie chess or something
like that it's basically like an open
source
free you know like kind of like
alternative and it's also doing
extremely well and those are like the
two uh but it seems like people kind of
prefer chess.com so i started thinking
okay
what's the nextchest.com what are the
others is there a whole slew of these
guys because i think that's where we
didn't talk about last time that we
should have and so i wanted to double
click in a little bit so i started
and that was that's a really really hard
question i've been thinking about it too
i only came up with like dominoes
i looked into solitaire websites they a
lot of them crush
but yeah that's a hard question to ask
so i i spent 10-15 minutes on it but
that was enough to tell me something
very interesting so the first one that
came to mind was because here's the
characteristics that you need
you need a game played by tens of
millions if not hundreds of millions of
people
that is not owned by a brand chess works
checkers also works but the problem with
checkers is it's so simple that it's not
as like uh
there's not as much depth to it
therefore not as much of a like kind of
like
uh money made and passion around the
sport
uh sudoku was the second one that came
to mind so i went to sudoku.com
and sudoku.com it's just like chess.com
it's like
you you go to snoke.com and there's
already a sudoku board waiting for you
with clock going
and it's like oh play here it is you
don't need to download you don't need to
sign up you don't need to do anything
just play sudoku
i love that then they you scroll down a
little bit and you see like this
advertisement for like a mobile app a
mobile sudoku app
so i click that i'm like i bet this app
i bet this is an amazing distribution
for this app
app crushes so this company called
easybrain behind it
so the sudoku app that they have has 50
million downloads
the uh on just google play forget about
iphone that's just google that's just
android
um probably 100 million total lifetime
downloads
the website itself gets you know 10 to
20 million visitors a month
uh so they're getting free basically
free traffic to their mobile apps where
they're able to monetize
and easy brain basically makes they're
like a mobile app developer
that makes these apps they've had over
750 million downloads lifetime of these
little simple
number game apps starting with sudoku
then like a remix of sudoku then like
another number game if you like that one
and they just cross promote them within
each other i bet this company
is crushing it they're based in europe
and that's like
i have information on on them i just
found some interesting stuff
when i googled them and went to the
website there was something amazing
about them
that immediately stuck out and and
just this quick google it i'm wrong but
it is based in cyprus any time a company
is based in cyprus
it's like it's turns out these guys
actually are
uh from like the belarus they're
actually from this area but they're
based in cyprus so
i just googled it real quick so uh did
you know that it was they were acquired
um three months ago no i did not know
this so that's
okay that's the other piece i have their
revenues i have their profit and i have
the uh all their user numbers and i have
can i guess
i'm gonna be totally wrong but i i like
to guess by the way
little tip always guess before you hear
any number that's how you get good at
knowing numbers
because you guess and then when you're
wrong your brain remembers that [__]
and you start to hone that kind of
instinct okay so here's here's my guess
okay well uh how much were they what
what's their revenue i'm gonna guess
that their revenue was
400 million dollars a year okay
what's their um profit
90 million dollars a year
pretty good um all right how much were
they required for
i'm gonna guess that they're required
for 852 million dollars
okay and how many um how many
daily active users do they have across
their 15 games
i'm gonna say they have 25 million dau
okay so i didn't do you didn't do
horrible okay so easy brain was acquired
uh last this most recent february
uh they were uh acquired for 640 million
dollars in stock
and up to 125 million dollars of
additional consideration if they hit it
so 640
yeah what is that that isn't that
exactly 8.50
no what six uh what 640 plus 100 is 740
plus 25 is 765.
so great job you guessed 850. great job
you're almost there
um they their revenue is uh in 2020
revenues were 210 million dollars
okay so you were off there by half you
guessed 400 million
but their profit was 70 million you
guessed 90.
right pretty good um they've had 750
installs
over the course of their the lifetime of
all their other things
all their games they have uh 15 live
games
with 12 million daily active users you
guessed 25 million
okay not bad not bad um what a company
so okay so that was the first one i
thought of and by the way i think that
there's
other versions of that like you know i
don't know go look at like
you know sudokuonline.com i don't know
what's that like
you know all the things people are going
to google search if you can get the top
level domain for those that's really
interesting
um so then i started looking at some
others poker.com
so i went to poker.com and poker.com is
like
kind of like this crappy like just
describe what you're looking at when you
go to it
let me look at this but you can't this
is an actual poker right
you're not betting it's not even a as
you can't play there it's just like
reviews here's it it's like an affiliate
site so it's like oh here's a place to
play poker
here's where you can go because they get
big kickbacks for basically sending a
player to pokerstars or wherever
if they deposit and so this is horrible
website
um crappy kind of like affiliate reviews
site dude you could do so much more with
this website like if somebody was like
dude i'm gonna
i have a if you have a mobile poker app
that's like good
i would pay like ungodly amounts of
money for poker.com i think that that's
a
and they also if you like do their
traffic search see what they get
it's nothing so they should be getting a
lot more traffic having poker.com
um okay so then there's some other ones
crosswordpuzzle.com
crossword.com the go to those like they
don't even like
crossroads.com or something it doesn't
even like render it's like a it's like
fun
astrix on the screen yeah like what's
going on here because crossword is the
other game that's like
sudoku it's like chess that people
played religiously
and they love we talked about how how
much the new york times makes off their
mini crossword game
the number was uh 90 million dollars in
subscription revenue from crossword
puzzles for the new york times
so so i'm surprised that crossword
puzzle across the puzzles.com
crossword.com i can't believe that these
sites are not being like
leveraged so i was very surprised to see
this and uh yeah look at this follow up
from this
so you go to crosswoodpuzzle.com
it says please email suggestions to dkw
999 at yahoo.com right
so i emailed the guy so so
so you see this the website is basically
like a white page with a bunch of text
and it's basically just the very bottom
things the very bottom it says this dome
no this domain is not for sale please do
not inquire about purchasing it
all emails from anonymous are unknown
companies asking me a price will be
ignored
sorry last updated july 2007
right so i emailed this guy and i was
like hey uh saw your
website um like i think it's awesome
that you're not trying to sell this
but i'm curious like why aren't you
trying to solve this and
uh what's your you know what do you want
this to be why do you believe like why
do you believe that it should be done
this way i
you know i'm just super curious like
what's your thought process so we'll see
if he replies
there's another website that's like this
so bray you see if you could find the
name of this i don't remember called
thumb head but
sam you might know this there is a
website that's like
it's like a misspelling of google.com or
gmail.com i think it might be gmail.com
or
something like that and it's the same
thing it's an all-white webpage
that's like yeah frank and susan you
know we were married in 1977 and like
blah blah
no if we are not going to put ads on the
site no we did not we owned this before
gmail came out
it's like they basically just have this
web page that gets like and they have a
counter of how much traffic they get
uh and they just show that they're
getting like hundreds of thousands of
hits a day
and like he's like refuses to monetize
it refuses to sell it i think it's
hilarious
what what is this what uh brady did you
find it
try to find it i'll find it after the
pod otherwise i i have this in my like
things to tweet about uh you know full
that's actually such a funny idea oh
so like if if we just looked at the most
visited website and find out what the
typos are for each one
and go and look at what those are so
like right if you go to goggle.com so
g-o-g-l-e
google owns it so it redirects you most
of the time the company owns like their
plurals and their misspells but
sometimes they don't and then
those are hilarious oh my gosh i just uh
i was looking at bing i change it to
bang don't go there found something else
yeah don't go there um what else is
there that's like a
what what's a like a like a youtube
spelled wrong like you can do like
facebook
uh but you could do like i don't know
like you you
lose the a or something like that i
don't know see what that is
god that's so interesting um that that's
actually an interesting thing
facebook owns facebook with 100. pretty
interesting that's actually an
interesting thing i'm going to research
that after this
i don't know if you know the guy who
owns bitcoin.com so this
guy roger van der whatever i don't know
his name is but he's like
kind of hated in the bitcoin community
by like 80 of the people because
he tried to create his own fork of
bitcoin so they forked bitcoin i think
it's bitcoin cash or
bitcoin satoshi's vision bsv i forgot
which one he's associated with i think
his bitcoin cash
but basically he created you know they
forked bitcoin and have their own
but this guy owns bitcoin.com and uh and
so he's like a billionaire guy from
bitcoin and like
he refuses to give up bitcoin.com but
it's like it's like points to the other
version of the not popular version of
bitcoin you know it's like the
this the fifth of jonah's brother who's
not in the band or whatever you know
it's like it's basically
like oh this is kind of a waste and
nobody can sue them because
it's there's no company behind bitcoin
and nobody owns the trademark
uh that's a pain in the ass i hate that
yeah i'm looking at it now
um let's talk about um
which one you want to go through we have
a bunch on the agenda here um
okay does this interest you well first
of all i want to tell you about a
company i just invested in
um and i want you to criticize it or
tell me if it's awesome okay oh you
actually read it okay so i'm doing we
just did a podcast a second ago and sean
talked about angel investing i've been
doing a little bit of angel investing
now
and my whole thing is i'm doing this
thing called a syndicate i almost did a
rolling fund like you but i didn't
really want like a full-time job
so i was like i'll just do this so it's
deal by deal or not a full-time job but
whatever it is for you
right um and my premise is this
and you confirmed it a little bit by
your reaction what i'm trying to do is
find
interesting deals that other angel
investors who i think are smarter than
me or other like firms who are smarter
than me are also investing in
but i try to find them where they're
explaining the company
really poorly and i'm spending time with
the founder listening to them and then
i'm rewriting
a memo about the company and i'm sending
it to people to invest in and it's kind
of working so i sent you one deck
and it was really bad it was confusing
um and then i just rewrote it and you're
like oh i want to invest in this company
maybe
yeah and it worked i was kind of gushing
i was like dude did they write this memo
like who wrote this memo i was like this
is the best investment memo i've ever
read you were like dude shut up
i just wrote some 20 minutes i was like
no no trust me i read a lot of these
things
and i was like it's all the memo was so
good that i had to separate
the writing which was really
entertaining and persuasive and likable
from the business because i was like
dude i don't want to just like convince
myself this is a good business i wanted
to be a good business i
you know like i love pitches where the
founder can just barely explain what the
hell they're doing but then i'm like oh
that makes total sense and i'm like yes
that's
like you you get it you're not like a
salesman
so i'm not like gonna invest in this
like hand-wavy [__] it's like no it's
real and it's working
and you're explaining it in kind of this
nonchalant way but it's actually
super legit you just don't like get
really excited and animated and you
don't have great
words to describe it yet uh and actually
i can help you with that
it sounds like you're thinking about the
same thing um i'm actually
thinking i'm going to simplify my thing
which is like just helping them with
their landing page and their
communication
because almost every company invest in
their landing page kind of sucks
and landing pages are really hard to
make good but um
they need a lot of help and it's like
something that not every other investor
is offering to do for them
and they actually are not that good at
doing it and so uh
anyways as i got off topic but your memo
was really great i actually want to like
publish it in some way
without like i don't know what you can
do but like i feel like that should be
public
uh i wanna point to that be like this is
great writing here's why you can go to
uh
you could if you like go to
angellisthamptonvc and you can invest if
you wanted to or you could even just
say you're gonna invest and then like
look at it um and then once it's done
i'll probably you can publish it or i'll
publish it
but they uh this company it's lobby.com
l-o-b-b-i-e
dot com uh it's so funny because
he actually did something really good
basically and this kind of sounds like
simple and negative but it's
it's it's a cool company i've invested
in it it's basically software that helps
doctors uh schedule appointments
or patients of schedule appointments
with doctors in a in just a good way and
it's kind of like an archaic
space but he was like we're making the
lobby digital
and like and i that's so much better
than creating than saying we are
creating
software that's just a crm for the
doctor's office
and i'm like they're like no we're
making the lobby room the lobby digital
we're going to save people so much time
and so basically the software what it
does is it
you can you can schedule an appointment
online and they'll alert you if the
doctor's running late
and when you get in the parking lot you
can tell them so you just wait your car
and they'll tell you when to come in
yada yada
um i mean it's like the interesting
thing about it is
the guy has already started and sold the
company in the space and uh it's
at worst gonna be okay at best might be
big
um anyway i just thought it was so
interesting
how it was digitizing the lobby or the
waiting room of healthcare
and i just wanted to bring that up
because i think it's so cool how they
repositioned that
to make something that isn't that cool
sounds kind of neat
right yeah you know that that's that's a
skill that's like a superpower
in and of itself uh i don't have a ton
of thoughts on the business itself
so i don't have too much to add there
but i agree with you basically the most
interesting part of talking about lobby
was your memo is so damn good and i
think we should uh show it to people so
that they can see
how do you explain how do you make a
business seem really juicy to be a part
of
uh to invest in because i think you did
a good job of that well that's what and
that's what we're gonna do so
i'm doing it with joe and i'll you and i
will probably do a bunch together i hope
where i'll invest in yours and you mine
and
the whole thing is i'm not trying to
sell
people i'm not trying to convince people
to do it um you either want to do it or
you don't like i'm not going to try and
convince you to do it
because that's that's kind of unethical
but i just want to paint the business in
the most positive light
or at least what i believe it to be
accurate like an accurate
it is cool and i want to make sure you
know it's cool and i think that this
whole copywriting thing for angel
investing might end up being
a a hit yeah i think it'll be it'll be
easy for you
to get people into your round because
people like you and
the memos are good so i think i think
those will be those will be good
i have a company i wanted to tell you
about that's a cool company um that i
think you're going to have a good
opinion on so
uh have you seen what keith reboy is
doing as his new startup
no so you know who he is yeah
so he's the guy who uh uh he was like ex
paypal then he was the ceo of square
he's
kind of a known investor at founders
fund then he started he's a known
[__]
like people think he's a total [__]
on twitter super hilarious to follow
because he's a
just absolute jerk to people um you know
his
like number one tweet is just like wrong
the period
and he won't tell you why he won't argue
back he just calls you an idiot and then
if you like try to argue he's like
this is why i'm i was more successful at
the age of 27 than you are at 40.
and he just like rips people like that
and like who does that that's
nobody does that so i think that's just
like really crazy and entertaining to me
um but anyways he's doing so he did open
door
and what open door is is now is like a
publicly listed company because it did
us back
and open door's a multi-billion dollar
company and basically it was like
selling your house is a time consuming
and stressful process what if like the
day you want to sell
you could just sell your house right
away give you a price you say yes or no
and that's what opendoor did so they
basically would just buy your house
and then they had a lot of data to know
how much to buy your house for
and then they were the brokers they
could keep the broker fee for themselves
buying and selling and then they would
sell it within like 90 days hopefully
and they do this in a whole bunch of
markets like arizona and stuff like that
and so they've done very well you know
kind of like on paper and like zillow
now like
does the same thing to try to compete
with them they kind of changed the way
that the the business model of these big
real estate companies worked where now
like the money to be made is in
basically like auto buying your bit auto
buying your house
and then reselling it for you and using
a bunch of technology to do that
anyways his new company he's starting uh
with with
jack abraham is uh called open store and
so
we have open door and now you have open
store i no they haven't released a bunch
of details but i think i know what it is
which is
it is open door for buying businesses so
it's the same idea for buying i think
it's going to be
specialized in online businesses but
maybe not um
where basically you just say here's my
business and then they say here's your
offer
we'll buy it off you and and so i don't
know if this is going to be specialized
like e-commerce roll-ups like a thrasio
um i don't know if it's going to be
online and offline like
uh where did you learn about this and
what what can i go is there a website
yet
uh they announced it so i heard about it
a few
weeks ago like six weeks ago maybe and i
was like oh that's super interesting
how did you hear about this so somebody
told me about it because
their friend interviewed at the company
and so that's like the only way you
could know about it because like when
you interview they like kind of tell you
the premise of the company
and that guy was like oh dude you know
keith was doing a new thing it's
basically open door for bit buying
businesses
and i was like oh that's sick that's a
great idea because buying
but selling your business is also just
like
is even more than buying a home in terms
of time consuming stressful
uncertain on what price you're going to
get uncertain what price it even should
be
and um and the marketplace is to do that
online like
buy biz buy biz sell or whatever that
website is like dot com
buy business sell they're so like old
school you know like on how they do that
and so um so i think there's like room
for improvement there
so i found that to be really interesting
let me bring this up real quick which is
it's so crazy how often
internet marketers who often are accused
of being sleazy
and many of them are i mean they're
accused of being that because they are
but
they're often ahead of the game so for
example
email marketing email newsletters are
all the rage right now uh
scammy guys like i don't think this
guy's actually scamming me but david
d'angelo used to sell dating books in
the 1990s by having these long emails i
just stole and copied from him
um the other thing is paid memberships
paid memberships have been a thing
for decades now guys like greg your
friend our friend greg
is doing a paid community thing and
greg's like a cool guy um and so it's
like
it's like cool to do it um and there's
so many more and this is another one
buying and selling businesses online has
been a thing that internet marketers so
for example flippa where you could buy
affiliate websites that's been a thing
for years empire flippers is another one
yeah
empire builders and if you go as empire
flippers or empire builders i think
those are actually two
but they but if you go to those websites
you're gonna
a lot of people are gonna be immediately
turned off you're gonna think what the
[__] is this
and [__] startup guys like us we just
come in i guess that's what we are
we just come in and we take the stuff
that these guys have been doing for
years and we just say
put some lipstick on it yeah one 2.0
make it a flat beautiful color
uh it's so funny because like cool this
sounds
neat but this isn't unique right uh yeah
i think you know there's no unique ideas
really there's you know remixes of ideas
there's old ideas that you make new
there's new platforms
but but i think it's cool and i think it
could be big
uh it's one i'm gonna keep my eye on
then i saw another business like this
so i started to put together a little
bit of a pattern here and i said oh
what is open door for x so what other
parts of life and and uh in the world
could use instant liquidity because
that's what this is it's basically
taking something that was kind of
illiquid like your house and
it takes a lot of time to get liquid
where you actually sell the thing
and takes a lot of pr you know you got
to like you got to move out you got to
stage it you got to repaint it you got
to get a broker you got to list it you
got to do tours
no instant liquidity we buy your house
today don't do any of that [__]
um same thing with your buying your
business what else needs that and then i
saw another one
and this business is called um i grabbed
the name but
it's basically doing this for used
electronics it's called backflip
just got funded and backflip is
basically saying we'll
instantly buy any of your used
electronics and uh because
that's not a new thing either and and i
think it's awesome
and so it's not that it's new it's
basically that there is a
big swing being taken by people who are
going to try to do this
at scale using like the modern kind of
internet marketing
and models to do it and so like you know
like
we buy gold or whatever what else those
billboards cards
you know like gift cards yeah exactly
like um and there's like a gift card
there's actually a gift card startup
that's crushes
uh that that basically took the old
bottle and just doesn't know
what's it called raise i think raised
yeah i'm i'm on their website right now
i'm looking at raise.com
holy [__] i can look at the traffic and
just tell you these guys are printing
money
yeah raise is gonna be like a billion
dollar plus win
uh and nobody even like hears about this
company nobody talks about this company
but
you know super simple business of like
you know gift cards the gift card
business
resale of gift cards essentially and so
uh so anyways i'm interested in this
open door for x which is basically
instant liquidity for things that were
pretty
interesting all right let's play off
that so houses
okay there's equity zen which i think is
badass
uh so equities then let's see what he's
in
kind of looks more like flippa than it
does like open door meaning like
it's kind of hard to get in it's kind of
obtuse you got to like sign up to see
[__]
not everything is there it's like a
10-step process
to do an investment it's like equity zen
is not
like it's not robin hood on my phone
where i can just like
do my thing and so like secondary shares
yeah it's like a shitty name like i
don't know like it's just bad all around
and forge global
is the other one it's like also bad i
don't know i feel like somebody can do
this better carter is trying to carter x
is trying to do this better
um right now which is like secondary
shares of private companies
yeah i'm not a fan of carta but um i
could see them doing well but i'm not
i'm not a fan of carter so i don't know
if i want them to be the best at this
um angel is also trying to do it there's
a bunch of people trying to do this
second
trying to do open door trying to do what
they're trying to do is a little bit
different they're just still trying to
do the marketplace
what opendoor did was different it
wasn't like open door wasn't just
another housing marketplace it was
i will buy the thing off you right now
because i know what i can sell it for
um and i'll i'm comfortable with this
five percent spread that i will
i will keep so you give up five percent
of your upside
but you get the certainty of it being
done now and
i'm comfortable in that five percent
spread so somebody would need to do this
for secondary shares would they just go
you want to sell your your company stock
done
and then i will figure out how to
re-flip this thing on the other side
with my own spread
so there's a few people that have done
this with furniture and furniture's
really hard because furniture doesn't
ship well
yeah um but there is if you i don't know
if you know i mean i buy i like buying
used furniture because you can get like
10 000 couches for like three grand um
and what's
oftentimes they're really nice used
furniture is not really a thing on the
internet uh or at least it's not hugely
popular but you could i think there is
still an
interesting way you can do this with
used furniture right um so i think
training cards is one so i know a lot of
people that have sports cards they
collect it as a kid it's in their attic
somewhere it's in a box
they kind of heard of cards are worth
something but they don't like they don't
know what they have they don't know what
it's worth
they don't have them graded they didn't
send them into psa and pay the money to
get them graded
so i think if somebody basically did the
shoebox model where you basically say
put it all in the shoebox and mail it to
us and we will pay you for it
uh we'll do all the work of figuring out
what it's worth and then we'll pay you
you know 70 cents on the dollar for for
what it's worth and like today you're
getting nothing for it
and like that that's the and if you
don't like our offer
we'll send it back and i think that
somebody did that they could
just hoover up all the long tail of like
trading cards that are out there
um that people are not doing anything
with that they want to monetize
that's interesting okay so uh we've
we've
furniture is not that good trading cards
pretty interesting because it's a lot
easier
cars everyone a lot of people do cars
carvana does cars and i think that that
is so sick they're a multi-billion
dollar
is that the same model they use where
they'll just instantly buy your car off
you
yeah like they'll buy it in a matter of
minutes which if you told me this like
years ago i'd be like no way that
can't be done but they made uh 5.6
billion dollars last year in sales so it
works okay so it's working open door for
cars working yeah
yeah it totally works um what else is
interesting what's a huge thing like
what's what are some of the bigger
assets that you possibly have in your
life that you want to
wow carvana's market cap is 45 billion
dollars holy [__]
yeah it's working um what else is there
i don't know there's gonna be some
obscure [__] like oh like life insurance
policy payouts or something or like you
know like something like that that i'm
like
i don't even know that space but that
makes sense it takes you know it's
something that you get or like social
security like
i know like my parents are getting to
the age where they can collect social
security
like would they take a lump sum of all
their social security now
and you know at at 70 cents or 72 cents
on the dollar
and then you know this company just
collects the the payments over time like
probably i don't know like there's a lot
of people who would make that trade dude
did you know this so there's this uh a
company i have to go and look at what it
is but you guys could probably google it
actually but i think some banks do it
like goldman will do it
but if you have a winning lottery ticket
they'll buy it off you right and they'll
give you the money up front
and it's structured in such a way where
they're they're still able to make their
profit but they'll buy lottery tickets
from you like we're talking like 10
million dollar lottery tickets or seven
figures
uh i i uh it's kind of interesting
people buy winning lottery tickets off
of people
that's actually kind of an interesting
one um i would actually need to do some
research
how many people do how much money do you
think is won in the lottery per year
oh dude i have no idea i mean i feel
like the weekly lottery the powerball
every week is like you know between 50
and like 200 million dollars it's like
it's like
that's that's like on a weekly basis
that it's so now it doesn't get one
every week that's how it accrues and
that's how it gets bigger but like
you know i don't know you have the
number in front of you i feel like it's
i don't know no i i uh no i i can't find
it there there's 1600 lotteries created
each year
so there's at least 1600 unique winners
um
no i don't i don't have the numbers but
lottery tickets might actually be kind
of interesting because you said the life
insurance i'm like what do you wait to
get paid for
that you would take a discounted upfront
payment lotteries is kind of is actually
kind of interesting
um and i do know that some banks
actually do that right
you know who else does that is whitey
bulger you remember whitey bulger
i've never even heard that those words
in my life do you do
you know the movie that departed yes you
know jack nicholas's character
okay yes it's modeled after whitey
bulger he was a gangster
in uh boston he was an italian or an
irish mafia guy
he uh mobster guy he ended up going to
jail recently they found him
and they um um he got beat to death in
jail so it was like a
crazy ending to the story of him he was
america's most wanted man for
like 20 years and um anyway he
as part of his story he won the lottery
three times and the way that he did it
is people who had won the lottery that
in the neighborhood
they would have to go to him and he
would buy it from you and he would go
and cash the ticket
and uh so this is like a fame like the
numbers game they call it that it's like
a famous mafia thing
wow okay i had no idea um yes i don't
know
maybe if people have good ideas on what
what part of life could use instant
liquidity
i'm curious to see to see what that that
would be um
okay so a couple other things i wanted
to bring up one is
a pain point or kind of a business
opportunity maybe this exists if it
exists tell me because i want to use
this
service so in e-commerce
most e-commerce brands are just local in
their own geographies and most are let's
say most u.s ecommerce brands basically
just sell in the u.s
and then it takes time and then you
start selling in canada and then you
start selling in europe and then
you know but it takes a long time and
the reason it takes a long time is
because of the like international
logistics so for example you want to
ship something to canada
they have to pay like pretty heavy duty
like a import duty
on the product so you sell like a 50
product they're gonna have to pay like
of import taxes in addition to the
shipping so it just becomes like
irresponsible to buy uh and still some
customers do because they can only get
the product from
the us-based company but it really sucks
and then the company has to like fill
out this form
that says these goods are worth 14 and
then you submit that at the thing and
it's just annoying right and so
i think there should be a company so
there's these brands trying to do these
e-commerce roll-ups
i think you should do it differently i
think some enterprising entrepreneur can
basically say look
i will boot up your canadian operation
today
i'll boot up your uk operation your
france operation yeah i'll do europe
i'll do
uk i'll do um australia whatever right
so basically say i'll
import your brand today you do no work
so all you have to do
is you need to ship me this product to
this warehouse so here's the address
ship me your products uh i need like you
know whatever your normal inventory is
ship 10 to me and let's see how i do
and basically you get one giant
warehouse where you're warehousing for
all the brands that you're going to work
with
and you just say look in exchange for
doing this you pay me no money i will
start generating sales for you
but i want a royalty i want a royalty of
10 cents or 15 cents for every dollar
but what's your point
what like how is this how's this
interesting or new
uh because i don't know of a brand that
does this that exists so
you know my wife has an e-commerce brand
we sell in the us i would love to be
making more money by selling in europe
but the time the operational overhead to
go to europe right now is just crazy
so why aren't there more people that are
reaching out to ecommerce store owners
and basically saying i will run your
international operation
and make it a low risk to no risk
proposition for them in order to do so
and i think there's a lot of money to be
made
given the number of e-commerce brands in
the us and
how you could if you're in brazil or
you're in australia or you're in canada
or wherever
i think you could become the leading
trusted like kind of like
we're we are your canada go to canada go
to market plan for canada
and we just do all the work for you this
is actually quite common in media
so there's business insider india
there's business insider australia
there's business insider germany i
believe
um and then uh um
i think i believe the wall street
journal does the same thing for those
same countries but there is buzzfeed
france
uh huffpo france huffpo australia it's
actually pretty common
in media um and obviously so so
is it run out of the us or they hire a
team there or it's
a local team there that just licenses
the brand basically
when they report the revenue it's under
licensing
and so i don't exactly know what that
means though because i was trying i was
thinking about us and i was like man we
have a lot of people
who are uh english as a second language
folks uh in germany
so like uh i guess germany i guess is
one of the most populous
i don't know i don't know numbers i
guess it's one of the most populous
places in europe
it's uh very business focused so you
know the germans liked us
um same with australia australians loved
us and i was like
yeah let's go do it but what the [__] do
i do do i just fly over there and just
start recruiting like
it's it's crazy i would love to partner
with them and then another thing is
in particular china and japan and
there's actually a whole word for this
there's a word
i can't remember what the word is but
there's a word that describes why it's
difficult to break into japan
um and the reason is is that the one
it's hard to break into an
island in particular japan and i would
love to have paid someone to be like hey
can you be my
japanese uh yeah consecuti like my
my capo on the ground those are all mob
terms because i'm into the mafia now
uh can you be my my guy on the street of
japan and let me know is this good am i
getting the right people i think that's
incredibly interesting
yeah exactly so i'm i'm not saying that
this doesn't exist i'm saying
there's still a lot of room there
because
i know a lot of people i have a lot of
friends who are doing e-commerce right
we host club ltv
there's you know 75 to 100 e-commerce
brands each doing over a million dollars
a year in there
and every single one of them i think has
the same problem which is that
we're all u.s focused and why are we us
focused because
it would be too much of a lift too much
of a lift to go figure out how to do
australia it's too small of a pie to
like
do manpower on or spend brain power on
but if somebody in australia was like
hey look this is what we do this is our
business model we
help you get sales here and we just take
our cut
and uh and so i just think that like
there needs to there's there's more
opportunity for this and that's cool
that in media it sounds like there's
also an opportunity to do it media too
or being done in some way by the big
players
it's being done in some way but like i
remember when buzzfeed
uh like we're going through some
troubles they had a layoff like their
whole french office and i was like
buzzfeed has a french office what the
[__]
well that's the opposite right that's we
have a french office and then you have
to do things like that when it's like
not working out i'm saying
no investment no consulting fees
you just take a royalty on sales and
these are all incremental sales that i
wasn't getting otherwise
and you take care of the whole
operational headache in this case for
e-commerce about like
i just ship your goods to your warehouse
you ship it to local customers customers
don't have to overpay
customers don't have to do import duties
uh for every order they make
and so i just think that there's a
opportunity in e-commerce to like be the
the go-to brand for every dtc brand
to partner with in each of these locales
what
country would you go to next um
i think europe is probably the best
because you want um what the you know
the next wealthiest
high populous place um but really it can
work anywhere it's just like the biggest
market
is doing it you know throughout europe
now europe
is made up of so many countries maybe
that's a pain in the ass if not like
canada's the no-brainer
australia next japan is a good one um
those would be the ones india maybe like
for example i know a bunch of people in
india who did this so
uh my dad introduced me to these guys
and i was like oh wow why is
these guys how their house is humongous
how you know what do they do
it's like oh yeah they um they partnered
with jockey underwear
and they just became the jockey like
seller here they have exclusive rights
to sell jockey in india
next guy at the dinner table what do you
do oh we're the dominoes guys in india
what yeah we're the exclusive franchisee
of dominoes for india
um okay what does that mean well we have
like indians didn't really eat pizza
before this so we're like teaching
people to eat pizza they [__] love it
turns out and so we have like you know 9
000 dominoes throughout india now like
oh my god what is going on here
it's like you know local franchisee but
for what's this called
what's the terminol what's the term for
this i don't know
you know maybe i should have gone to
business school i think it's probably
just like in brick and mortar i think
it's just called franchising
um franchising was the way to sp spread
geographically
you know when your brick and mortar can
only scale so fast uh that's how you
would do it you would franchise out and
then the franchise would pay a royalty
back to the back to the
master franchise of the brand uh of
their sales
and they're the local operator but with
e-commerce or with digital media
it's a little bit different but it kind
of has the same problem so i don't know
if there's a new word for it
man i think this is wildly fascinating
this is i didn't think it was that
interesting at first but now i know what
you're talking about where
uh i've heard so many stories of the
same thing but not maybe not of india
but i am the official
uh importer of x y and z yeah we're the
distributor of x
or like for you just think about for
your business right like would could you
have sold for more
if you had like 250
000 you know or like 500 000 subscribers
in japan
and like dude i think there's a world
where i would have been where i could
have made more money in those markets
than i did in america because even
though america has more people
um i don't think the french or i don't
think that the germans
um i don't think facebook kicks as much
ass over there as it does here
with instagram and everything and so i
think the ad markets because i i do
think that europe
sorry europeans if you're listening i do
think that you guys are five or ten
years behind
when it comes to some technology stuff
um and
the ad markets suck because of facebook
and google so like
if you could still capture a little bit
of that revenue i think you could
well i don't know if any of that's true
but what i do know is that it's true
trust me as you're building
well i think like everybody uses
facebook everywhere so that's the part
i'm saying i don't know
um well sorry but what i mean is like
old media
still does quite well abroad okay that's
fair that's fair
uh the thing i'm just saying is like if
while you were building your us business
and all your employees are focused on
your u.s business if somebody said i
love your product i'd love to license
the brand from you or
or i'd love to be your partner in
in the uk or in japan or in australia
and i will build
i will use the same playbook it'll be
under your company i just want my cut
for building this for you because i'm
going to private you would have done it
in a heartbeat right and so the fact
that you didn't
means there was an opportunity for some
entrepreneur that should have been
reaching out to you saying
this is a no-lose proposition you still
own it you still make money off of it
it's still your name brand i just get to
go i get to basically take your brand
take your head take your product
and localize it or distribute it here
where i am from and i know the market
yeah
and my product's way easier than yours
it was cause it's pixels
it's not anything real and i would have
loved to have done that and i used to
have people emailing me all the time and
then we had a bunch of people in russia
some people in mexico
who would just verbatim copy our [__]
and i would say i would have to
i'd find it and i'd be like you guys
stop this dude you're not allowed to do
this
and then i'd have other people who would
email me be like hey can i try could you
stop anyone from doing that i feel like
you can't do [__] if somebody
takes your newsletter and they just word
for word transcribe it in russia and
they're like
we're called whatever how hustle are you
no there's nothing you could do
the only thing that i was able to do the
only thing i was able to do we had
someone do this an uh italian we had
somebody in russian and we had someone
do it in mexico uh
yeah mexico and i basically shamed them
i said like
i'm just gonna i'm just going to call
you out and so i would tweet at them or
i would email them
uh i would just would make it well known
and my network was large enough that
someone
of someone knew them and they were
embarrassed and they
yeah and they stopped doing it but no i
didn't do [__]
yeah and i had people email me all the
time saying hey can i do this for
uh spain and i would say yeah but i
don't really know anything about you
i don't know if you've got good taste i
don't like i don't i know nothing about
you
and i would just throw it off to the
side and just kind of forget about it i
wish i would have i'm surprised this
doesn't happen more i'm surprised
there's not just like
freemedia.com based in cyprus that
basically takes all the content from
behind the paywall of wall street
journal
and just says cool if you ever hit a
paywall
come here look like input put the url
you're trying to go to
here's the article for free i'm
surprised somebody hasn't just tried to
do that like it's totally bootleg it's
piracy
right but like it is so hard to enforce
that stuff
i can't believe that somebody
internationally isn't doing that that
seems like the way to do it
do you know what outlined.com is i know
about it and i know i don't know what i
could say publicly about it but
uh yeah i know explain it i don't have
any insider information so maybe you do
i i don't i'll explain why
so outline.com it's uh the tagline is
read and annotate without distractions
frankly
i have no idea what that means but the
way that i use it and the way that
everyone else uses it is when you come
across a paywall website
you put the url into outline.com and you
can see the whole article
um it just it doesn't work for
everything i don't think it works for
new york times
but uh you can get you can get like
i think a bunch of bunch of sites they
they kind of stopped working on but
initially it worked on everything
and uh the person behind this is
somebody we know that's like a
well-known kind of tech person that
works at one of the big companies and
was like
they had to like distance themselves it
was getting like millions of hits
like people were using this thing they
had to distance themselves from it
because they were like uh yeah
like i was kind of told i had to knock
it off he's like i didn't make it for
that purpose it just it works that way
but uh yeah is it a brazilian
no sight oh my god oh
okay i uh yeah yeah i see
yeah i know who you're talking about how
interesting outland.com
what the heck it's that big i just
googled it uh or i just looked at a
similar way about how big it was
outlined.com
crazy fascinating yeah so so i think
that one's cool
um all right i'll bray you how did we do
on the
wait hold on yeah just a quick question
does outline.com make money
uh i don't think so i don't know i have
no idea
wow this person is so interesting all
right uh
that's it that's the episode uh by the
way for the people listening
we actually just did like a q a before
this it was
sean i think it was too much talking we
got to do the q and a in the second half
because oh yeah i'm [__] exhausted
right now but like i feel like there's
so much
drain from my body right now no
if we're going to do two hours again we
have to do the i'm trying to be lifting
in the front
i tried to keep the energy high but like
in my brain and i also haven't eaten
anything today so i'm just like dying on
all fronts right now
i'm hurting i'm hurting yeah q a is
going to be a separate episode dude
so we are we're getting two episodes out
of this yeah
we gotta i can't do it next time yeah
yeah i thought we would be able to but
yes this is painful maybe this is hard
instead
of the way for another one tomorrow
yeah i can do another one tomorrow i can
do i can do one a day
easy uh i think i think i can yeah we'll
have to try something else
if we want to keep doing the q and a's i
like that one i thought the q a was
almost better than the actual episode
maybe because you guys were tired but
the q a came out a lot better than i
thought
i think people are gonna like both of
those yeah no the whole thing is good
so good job guys
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like no days off on
the road less travel
never looking back